los bucaneros de tampa bay han hecho
historia al convertirse en el primer y
único equipo local en ganar la super
bowl las leyes de las ciudades se han
llenado de aficionados del equipo que no
podían esconder su emoción cuando el
marcador apuntaba al final del encuentro
31 a 9 contra los kansas city chiefs que
partían como claros favoritos tras la
victoria del año pasado pero más allá de
lo puramente deportivo este encuentro ha
tenido en vilo a los expertos sanitarios
y se habían estimado todas las medidas
de seguridad sanitarias sólo entraron 22
mil personas aproximadamente un 20 por
ciento de la capacidad total del estadio
en la nfl tuvo un sexto solidario para
que los médicos y regalos 7500 boletos
para los sanitarios que han estado
batallando al frente de la pandemia en
el medio tiempo uno de los momentos son
más esperados se ha realizado de una
forma excepcional de weekend actos sin
público sin muchas pretensiones y desde
la grada nada que ver con lo que se
había visto en años anteriores la razón
era el coronavirus y su alcaldesa me
había ordenado el uso
de mascarillas en cualquier lugar al
aire libre
aquí en tampa una medida que no se ha
cumplido en absoluto porque mucha gente
ha salido a la calle sin mascarilla y
sin respetar las distancias de seguridad
la mayor preocupación de las autoridades
es que tras este encuentro deportivo en
el que tiene más audiencia en eeuu haya
un pico de contagios como pasó después
del 4 de julio o tras las celebraciones
del fin de semana del día de acción de
gracia 21 que de cada cuatro
estadounidenses había dicho lo que iba a
participar en fiestas multitudinarias
así que muchos temen que la pandemia
empeoren el país